Deadpool 3 has resumed filming and now
we are getting some more leaked set
photos of Deadpool and Wolverine and
what's really great about this movie is
that even though we are seeing these set
photos a lot of this movie Still Remains
a pretty decent mystery despite all the
reports of the movie that we have we
know that this movie is primarily still
going to be focused on Deadpool and
Wolverine and whatever that particular
story is we don't necessarily know it
however it looks like recent set photos
combined with recent reports about what
is going to happen in Deadpool 3 lead us
to know one major factor of what is
going to happen in Deadpool 3 and where
exactly it's going to happen it also
looks like thanks to the new set photus
that we've seen that we have a major
confirmation for a insane story that
they could be adapting that they
hopefully are adapting in Deadpool 3 and
that is Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe however of course we believe
that it is going to be Deadpool kills
the fox universe and it's not even
limited to just the fox universe but any
universe that he might happen upon in
his multiversal travels so two very
important plot details for Deadpool 3
that we're going to talk about today
that are revealed with these recent set
photos so be sure to subscribe to the
channel if you're new so you don't miss
out on any of the latest Deadpool in MCU
news also if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win a PS5
an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items we pick one
winner at the end of each month and the
winner picks one item so by far the
biggest thing that we've heard about
Deadpool 3 from Insider reports is that
a multiversal Avengers team heroes team
is going to be assembled in the film
keep in mind we say Avengers but the
team will also consist of the Fantastic
Four X-Men members and other Heroes as
well the premise of the multiversal team
assembling in Deadpool 3 is because of
the TVA the TVA is brought into the
story of Deadpool 3 because in the
beginning well really at the end of
Deadpool 2 Deadpool used cable time
travel device and started time traveling
and although the TVA has seemingly
changed and really their main focus is
Kang right now one can see how Deadpool
going around in different points in time
creating Branch timelines could cause
some trouble just because it's
specifically Deadpool you could see how
Deadpool could probably cause some
incursions to happen so that's how the
TVA gets brought into Deadpool 3 now
from there we have heard that the TVA is
going to go to different universes and
start saving specific Heroes they need
to fight on their giant Multiverse
Avengers team to take on King the
Conqueror and his variants now we've
known about this for a bit but these set
photos from Deadpool 3 give us a little
bit more insight to this new set photos
have revealed in the same scene that
we've seen Deadpool and Wolverine fight
in two new factors one is a truck that
seems to be a modified version of the
truck that was in moonnight and another
is what is seemingly Red Skulls car from
the very first Captain America film how
did they end up here well this pretty
much confirms that this scene right here
takes place in the void we've already
seen other random things appear like the
20th Century Fox logo but here's why the
void is very important to Deadpool 3 one
is that this is a place where we are
most likely going to see some pretty
cool Easter eggs and cameos we've
already seen with these new set photos
an original X-Men show up we're not
going to say who or show who in case
some of you out there are trying to
avoid the spoilers but the new set
photos do show one of the original X-Men
characters from that Old universe in the
void so needless to say most of the
reports about some of the original X-Men
returning and cameos Galore are true
it's a multiversal film so what can you
expect we've even heard from The Insider
can we get some toast that parts of
Deadpool 3 will take place during the
original X-Men Trilogy so that's just
super exciting to look forward to that's
one reason the void is going to be a
great location but the other is that
this is most likely where the TVA is
going to take all of the heroes that
they save now first thing to note that
you have to keep in mind is that even
though Loki season 2 just happened the
events of Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum
Mania in the post-credit scene those
events still happened as well and even
though Loki season 2 came after Quantum
Mania keep in mind that most of that
took place outside of time and space so
technically the events that happened in
the post credit for Quantum Mania only
happened because of the events that took
place in Loki season 2 The Multiverse
only exists right now because of Loki
season 2 so you have to keep in mind in
the back of your head that King the
Conqueror thousands of them millions of
them infinite amounts of King variants
are out there and they are now Gathering
Together the Council of Kings the king
Trio lead them and they have basically
told us that they have done a lot
already amort says if we let them
referring to the Avengers they will take
everything we've built meaning they have
conquered a lot already a lot of
different universes and have built an
Empire and we can see that due to all of
the followers they have all of the Kang
variants so logically we can assume
since the Council of Kings has built
such a huge Empire already and has
conquered a lot of the Multiverse that
when the TVA starts going to different
universes and taking specific Heroes the
Council of Kings is going to notice this
at some point in time they're going to
notice what's going on and with infinite
amounts of Kang variants we have to
believe that at least one of them on
their side has created the TVA before so
they're going to know exactly what the
TVA is there is no way that only one
variant of Kang he who remains has
created only one TVA and we've heard
that Loki is going to return for secret
War so I believe that at some point in
time the Council of Kings is going to
try and find the TVA somewhere outside
of space and time they're going to try
and track that location that technically
doesn't exist because it's not in space
or time but they're going to try to
track it down because they understand
time travel they understand space the
Multiverse so they'll be able to find it
so the TVA can't exactly assemble this
Multiverse Avengers team at the TVA
they're going to need somewhere else to
do it and I believe that could be at the
void at the end of time and they have
essentially kind of set this up already
in Loki season one we learned that the
void had become an amalgam of alternate
realities it's a mixture of a ton of
different universes which is essentially
what we are going to get in secret Wars
a lot of different universes coming
together and we can assume there has to
be some type of a scene where all the
heroes and possibly some villains come
together and talk about what they're
going to do I believe the void is the
place where that happens and they could
even possibly use elath to help protect
them to help guard them from other Kang
variants if they would happen to find
them but this is a great place where
they could go unnoticed by all of the
Kang variants and where they could
essentially assemble we've even heard
recently that in Deadpool 3 there's
going to be somewhat of a portal scene
just like from Avengers endgame but it's
going to be sort of a parody and
Deadpool is actually going to make fun
of it and it would make sense that this
would happen in the void a place where
all the realities kind of mix and come
together now also at the same time like
I mentioned this could be kind of the
start of Deadpool kills the fox Universe
since we've seen in the void the 20th
Century Fox logo we assume Deadpool is
either going to escape or work with the
TVA somehow he might get a prune stick
and go around and start pruning we know
there's going to be a lot of fighting
and a lot of death in this movie caused
by Deadpool and Wolverine we also know
that they're going to be traveling
throughout the Multiverse but what's
interesting about the void is that they
stated in Loki season 1 when they prune
a branched reality it's impossible to
destroy all of its matter so they move
it to a place on the timeline where it
won't continue growing that could be
what we see here with this 20th Century
Fox logo Deadpool could have killed the
entire timeline but they couldn't get
rid of all of the matter so they moved
some of it hint the logo to the void the
same thing goes with these other items
that we are seeing here and these other
characters that could end up in the void
as well the fox universe is getting
destroyed and the fox Universe probably
consists of several different ones right
one original X-Men trilogy universe
another X-Men first Class although
they're kind of the same universe but
alternate timelines exist as well but
Deadpool goes around killing a bunch of
different universes and some of the
remnants of those universes end up in
the void which is where Deadpool and
Wolverine ultimately end up in and for
some reason end up fighting a lot to
look forward to with Deadpool 3 but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below do you think the
void is the place where the Multiverse
Avengers team assembles and does
Deadpool completely kill the old Fox
Universe let us know your thoughts down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof